hey guys welcome back to the
strokerville 2 youtube channel
for this video we are going to tune the
idle
mixture screws on this edelbrock
carburetor
now this is a 1406 performer 600 cfm
electric tro carburetor but it's the
same
process for all the edelbrock
carburetors a couple things to know
about
this whole procedure your goal is to
have the engine running
as best as possible while also being as
lean as possible and remember these are
idle
mixture screws it only applies when you
are idling
as soon as you hit the gas these screws
are doing nothing
so there's no reason to be rich in this
position because all you're doing is
getting worse fuel economy there's no
power gain or anything and you're
probably going to follow out your spark
plugs you have a screw on the right
that's the right side you have a screw
on the left that's the left side as you
screw in you are making it leaner as you
screw
out you are making it richer so
we want the best running we can while
also having the screws
in as much as possible now to determine
how the engine is running
the best way to do it is with attack you
want the highest rpm
you use the attack in your car might be
a little bit more difficult you just go
by your ears
but your goal is to get the highest rpm
otherwise you can also use a vacuum
gauge
and you're going to go off that port
that's on the driver's side
right there that's manifold vacuum and
then
in that instance you're going for the
highest vacuum
so we prefer going by rpms but you can
go by vacuum if you don't have
a good way of going by rpms the other
thing is
if you play around with those screws and
absolutely nothing's happening at all
then you gotta take the carburetor off
and clean it so the first thing you have
to do when making any carburetor
adjustments
is get it warmed up you want the engine
at operating temperature
also we prefer to do this with the air
cleaner on
but honestly it's a real pain so you
might not be able to
not a huge deal if you can
we got the engine warmed up
and we want to set our idle at about 800
and that's our starting point
all i have is a back engage so that's
how we're going to do this one
the actual number doesn't matter for our
purposes
all we care is the highest number is the
best number
a good starting point on your screws is
to screw them
all the way in and then back out one and
a half turns
so we're gonna do that on each side
one half
carry this one
half one half
now we're going to start one side at a
time i'm going to start with the
driver's side
hopefully we'll both be able to see the
vacuum gauge you might have to move it a
little
but we're going to start by screwing
out the driver's side
screw
[Music]
i know it's hard to see the vacuum gauge
but the best place i can put it
again the value doesn't matter we just
wanted as high as possible
we're starting out one and a half turns
out on the driver's side
and we're going to continue vacuuming
we're going to continue backing
it out and watch the gauge
and now we're at two
two and a half seconds gone up a little
bit
at three we're going back down so we're
gonna go back to two and a half
where we got our highest vacuum
now we wanna check the tack if it raised
more than 40 or 50 rpm you want to set
it back down to 800. so let's check that
the rpms did go up just a hair but not
enough for us to mess with it let's do
the passenger side
thing on the faster side we're starting
one and a half turns out
we're going to continue going out while
watching the vacuum
that's two
and a half
and at three you can see it going down
just a little bit
so we're gonna go back to two and a half
and now we can fine tune them just a
little bit to see if we can sneak any
more vacuum out of this so we're going
back to the driver's side
and we'd rather be lean than rich
so we'll go in just a little bit
you see we got a little bit more vacuum
about a quarter of a turn in
and a half of turns not doing this any
better
so we're gonna go back about a quarter
turn from where we were
and try the same thing on the other side
so
and the passenger side was actually good
i ended up in the exact same spot that i
left it
the time before now that we have them
both adjusted
we're going to check the tack again
so the tack is pretty steady but it did
raise a little bit more
i'm gonna adjust that down just a little
bit and then we're all done
that's how to adjust the idle mixture
screws
on your edelbrock carburetor thanks for
watching
give the video a like subscribe for
already subscriber we're gonna do a
whole series of videos on
tuning this carburetor so be sure to
stick around check them out
i'll see you guys next time